the key point there is you've got to
enjoy what you do every day and for me
that's working with very smart people
it's working on new problems you know
every time we think hey we've had a
little bit of success we're pretty
careful not to dwell on it too much
because the bar gets raised that means a
tougher more often not always the pre
fanatical about the thing they're trying
to do I remember one industry panel
where there were about seven people the
debate was with the computer of these
being this character mode thing or would
it be graphics news on her face and at
the time the graphics interface that was
so slow it's laughable and writing
software is so bad but this Windows on
point and so the people on the panel
were saying down on this this is kind of
a stupid thing and I was saying none of
believing this would be green and one of
the guys on the panel said that that a
bill is wrong but I still works harder
than the rest of us so even though it's
the wrong solution he's likely to
succeed and that was the best pump than
I ever had was it just by working day to
night I can send you to the stream son
when we direction inside you know I
would spin out but when that period of
time that is I didn't believe in
vacation I didn't believe in weekends
you know so it turned out that work for
me that we got our company going into
speed does allow them to make mistakes
faster than than other people were in
kind of see those mistakes you just
watched two amazing clip with Bill Gates
take the next three minutes and sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]